forest à mesure que nous nous approchons
du salon de l'auto qui aura lieu à
partir de la fin du mois de septembre
les grands constructeurs dévoile
quelques-unes de leurs armes secrètes
luc bazin et frédéric de la rue ont pu
assister en avant-première à la
présentation du nouveau monospace de
citroën dans ce secteur déjà très
encombré la marque aux chevrons essaye
de se distinguer en baptisant son modèle
picasso
l'image d'un peintre et surtout son nom
utilisé par citroën pour promouvoir un
nouveau modèle de la marque picasso sera
donc aussi une voiture en fait un
nouveau monospace de taille moyenne soit
un peu plus de 4 mètres avec cinq places
à bord l'automobiliste passe
malheureusement de plus en plus de temps
dans les bouchons
d'où le besoin d' espaces intérieurs de
rangement et de sièges modulables
elle sortira à la fin de 1999 pas avant
et livraisons sont prévues dans la
deuxième partie que décembre 99
parce qu'on n'est pas encore prêts pour
le faire avant et je crois que ça
complètera très très bien la gamme xsara
on ne comptait que deux monospaces
différence sur le marché français en 92
aujourd'hui dix fois plus la renault
scénic réalise à elle seule la moitié
des ventes de ce segment très convoité
d'où la multiplication de ce type de
véhicules opel sortira par exemple
prochainement la zafira fiat l' multipla
moyens monospace avec deux rangées de
trois sièges et citroën s'apprête à
produire d'ici quatre ans un autre
monospace de dimension encore plus
réduite inspiré de ce prototype présenté
en avant-première le c3 une petite
voiture à l'intérieur très spacieux
c'est la nouvelle tendance automobile
vers laquelle tous les constructeurs
s'oriente pour satisfaire leur appétit
[Musique]